Jimmy thank from gamespot here at e3
2016 i'm here at ian's where's booth
speaking with alienware general manager
Frank azor and Frankie tell us what
we're looking at here so we've been
invested in virtual reality now with
oculus and HTC is pretty much since the
beginning and one of the biggest
problems when you're in the virtual
reality experiences having to worry
about the cable even if you're in a
seated experience if you're moving
around and stuff you're turning around
that cable keeps bringing you out of
that virtual experience and making you
conscious of the real world again and it
really compromises the immersive pneus
of your experience so we've been looking
at ways to go and solve that and one of
the things that we've done is we've
partnered with the company out in
Australia called zero latency VR and
what they've done is they've taken our
brand new alpha R to product that we
just launched yesterday actually been
working with them on this for a few
months and have created a backpack
solution where they slide in alpha R 2
over here in the top of the backpack all
the cables and everything come out the
top they connect directly to your head
mounted display and they can support
pretty much any head mounted display out
there I'm going to have a large battery
pack over here that allows them to
create a free roam VR experience they're
basically taking the entire compute
putting it on your back and now they can
create this experience where you can
have four versus four or five versus
five players in a virtual world
basically in any type of an environment
you're basically in the matrix right you
have free roam ability you're not
constrained to that four by four space
for example that you may have to work
within with oculus touch or with HTC you
can work within a three hundred square
foot radius or something like that so
this is actually something that's
already live it's running in melbourne
australia with our partner zero latency
vr and it's one way that we've been able
to go up and solve this problem today
we're also looking at ways to go and
solve this problem and a little bit more
of an elegant solution so let me
introduce you to another concept that
we're working on over here so this is a
concept that we're actually in
development now with a few partners
around building a completely self
enclosed vr capable system for all V our
applications out there
so what this does is this takes desktop
and mobile parts and puts them on your
back to give you the ability to power
like I said any VR content that's out
there whether it be on the oculus
library or the steam VR library and what
we've done is we've put a bridge battery
inside the heart cut the contraption
itself and then on the side here you
have two hot swappable batteries as well
so the entire thing weighs about four
and a half pounds the compute device
over here and then I'm the batteries way
a little less than a pound each and you
don't need to have both in there if you
don't want to on but if you want to go
for like an extended period maybe an
hour or more then you can put you can
put both packs in there as you're
running out of battery life you know you
can swap out the battery packs both of
them can be disconnected because you've
got the bridge battery inside the
computer vice as well and I itself and
yeah you can just keep going almost
infinitely without ever having to reboot
the device or or recharge it or anything
like that you just have separate
recharging harnesses if you will or cap
packs or yeah packs for for the
batteries and yeah it's kind of like an
infinite run device here so a lot of
work went into Devon building this so
that it be shocking vibe ready for the
type of environment that is going into
and like I said this is something that
we've partnered with AMD on and we're
considering it bringing to market we're
looking for folks to give us feedback if
this is something that they they want to
use at home or in commercial
applications like with zero latency and
some others are doing out there yeah I
was going to ask you is this for is this
for consumers or do you guys mean it is
it is it for like you know BR arcades or
something like that like how do you
envision it coming out to the market
this is a kind of a single-purpose
device right this is on the way it's
designed and everything the form factor
it's tough to put this on a desk and use
it as a desktop computer so this is more
going to be for a commercial application
for VR arcades of which we're seeing a
bunch of them pop up all over the
country now all over the world really
starting with zero latency VR and that
we've got other partners as well they're
doing it here in the US but there's
nothing that prevents folks from going
out there and buying this if they want
to use it at home the economics may not
make sense because this is going to be a
little bit expensive and it's only kind
of single purpose you're still be
holding to your houses
houses your home's lighthouses as well
i'm gonna be operating in a four by four
or five by five space so what may make a
little bit more sense is something like
with zero latency there where you can
get an alpha or two or a small product
like that and make it V are capable and
then use it as a multi-purpose device
you can use it as your desktop when you
want to a console one do you want to or
stop it into the backpack solution and
use it in that use case so I kind of get
a three in one product that way instead
of like a single purpose device and then
still having to have a desktop or a
notebook as well to do all your regular
compute can you walk us through you know
what you're thinking about putting
inside like a spec wise I know you
mentioned something about AMD and we
haven't announced the specs yet but it's
in a partnership with AMD on there with
their graphics so we're looking at
polaris generation graphics inside this
product that would be v are compatible i
mean Andie's done some really amazing
work around bringing vr capable graphics
to form factors and price points that
are really disrupting what it's taken to
be able to power vr up to now so that's
really interesting to use their
architecture inside a product like this
and then we're looking at some of their
cpus as well as well as intel cpus for
this we have concepts of this already
running but we haven't decided fully yet
on what the hardware architecture is
we're kind of leaving it open because
some of our partners may have their
preferences in the commercial
application space as so what they want
to work with of how they designed their
applications they may be better
optimized for one company or the other
so we're remaining flexible on exactly
what we're putting in here going i'm
guessing these things are using like
SSDs or something because as I
understand it moving around with the
mechanical hard drive probably not a
great idea I can like you know destroy
data whatever a key comment on that yeah
you don't really need a large capacity
to put inside these things so they're
typically running one or two apps
typically in a commercial type of
environment so yeah it's very easy for
us to put an SSD in here even though
mobile hard drives the everyday they
have very high shocking vibes out there
so this is not going to be like taking a
beating in the sense that it's going to
deal with massive shock so it wouldn't
really be an issue for us to put a
notebook spinning hard drive in here but
SSDs going to be more likely to be the
preferred option for the performance
benefits of it and having you know
one less thing to worry about in terms
of a rotational drive I didn't getting
rid of the cable as you know it's a good
thing but you know the trade-off is you
got to carry around this big backpack
are you guys putting a lot of
consideration into the ergonomics and
the weight and things like that
absolutely like I said it's gonna be
about four and a half pounds and using
the bridge batter you'll get about 30
minutes or so if you don't want to have
any of these external battery packs
alone on this being in VR for 30 minutes
right now that's it's a lot of time
actually in VR is not a lot of people
except for maybe that guinness world
record holder that did it for like over
24 hours not a lot of people are
spending that much time in VR in the
session but yeah if you want it if you
want to go in longer than you just come
with a little bit more weight for you to
be able to do it but yeah overall like I
said it's about four and a half pounds
that was a very important design
consideration for us so the materials
were using the components we put on the
motherboard for example it's only the
essentials you need in there because
we're being so weight sensitive gotcha
in a final question I know it's a still
a prototype in early idea but you guys
have any idea as you know as the price
of release date we actually don't it was
still just a concept like I said we have
prototypes running in the lab right now
we're looking for folks to give us
feedback at CES earlier this year we ask
folks to give this feedback on our oled
13-inch laptop we got an overwhelming of
a response from that and now we just
launched that yesterday so that's kind
of what we're doing we want to involve
the community we want to involve our
fans and customers listen to what they
have to say reach out to us on Twitter
Facebook and ad-aware arena com if this
is something you think you'd be really
interested in let us know what do you
think the price point should be when
would you like to see it launch what do
you think the components should be and
then we'll collaborate together and
bring it to market cool thank you Frank
for more coverage of e3 check out
gamespot com
you